jeden tag stehen in deutschland 45
millionen menschen auf und gehen zur
arbeit das sind so viele wie noch nie
zuvor das ist rekord und rekord klingt
erst mal toll was aber auch wahr ist für
einige reicht das was sie in ihrem job
bekommen kaum zum leben
sie schuften haben mehrere jobs und
kommt trotzdem passt nicht über die
runden sowie diana erkel sie arbeitet 40
stunden die woche
und er trotzdem kaum was übrigens das
macht mir schon wütend und deprimiert
dass man mit wirklich harter arbeit sein
leben so mehr schlecht als recht
bestreiten kann
das ist lone star bereit das ist nichts
anderes in der paketbranche im handwerk
in der pflege oder auf baustellen oder
beim putzen millionen menschen in
deutschland sind obwohl sie arbeiten für
sie sind lohndumping und ausbeutung an
der tagesordnung aber wie kann das in
einem reichen land wie deutschland seien
dafür schauen wir uns zusammen drei
punkte an erstens wehrt sich das
entwickelt zweitens wie konnte es
überhaupt so weit kommen und dann
natürlich welche ideen gibt es um das
problem zu lösen
[Musik]
schauen wir uns die entwicklung der
letzten jahre an
auf der einen seite ist es ganz klar so
noch wächst die deutsche wirtschaft
immer weiter und immer mehr arbeitslose
kommen in arbeit
man könnte ja meinen dann müsste auch
das armutsrisiko in deutschland sinken
die tendenz geht in den letzten jahren
aber eher nach oben
das heißt der aufschwung kommt überhaupt
nicht bei allen an und kritiker sagen
während es viele menschen im land
bessergeht geht die lohnschere weiter
auseinander
dieser graph hier zeigt die
einkommensentwicklung der letzten 30
jahre
und damit trifft armut eben nicht nur
arbeitslose sondern auch menschen die
arbeiten und das sind nicht nur ein paar
einzelfälle sondern millionen menschen
wie eben auch diana 2030 sind meine
einnahmen 1480 sind meine ausgaben
unterm strich bleiben ja 549 euro übrig
und für das geld muss ich dann halt auch
noch einkaufen das reiche deutschland
steht echt nicht gut da auch nicht im
vergleich mit anderen eu staaten von
2004 bis 2014 ist die erwerbs armut in
deutschland stärker gestiegen als in
jedem anderen land der europäischen
union als erwerbs angeht jemand der
armutsgefährdet ist obwohl er arbeitet
und als armutsgefährdet gilt man wenn
man weniger als 60 prozent des mittleren
einkommens zur verfügung hat das ist die
sogenannte relative armutsrisiko
definition das heißt wer hierzulande
armistice im vergleich zu anderen
deutschen arm im vergleich zu einem
typischen rumänen hat er mehr im
vergleich zum typischen schweden weniger
ob zeitverträge mini jobs oder
leiharbeit das problem ist real viele
menschen in deutschland schafften im
niedriglohnsektor
etwa ein viertel der beschäftigten das
ist historisch hoch 41 millionen
menschen arbeiten vollzeit für
niedriglöhne also im osten für höchstens
1.800 fünf euro brutto und im westen für
höchstens zwei 1289 euro brutto wir
haben einen der größten
niedriglohnsektoren innerhalb der eu und
damit auch viele menschen die spätestens
im alter von armut bedroht sind seit der
mindestlohn 2015
geführt wurde gibt es zumindest eine
untergrenze aber selbst wer den
mindestlohn verdient ist nicht so weit
weg von der armutsgrenze
und all das kommt nicht von ungefähr
schauen wir uns mal an wie es dazu
kommen konnte
denn fest steht die politik hat den
niedriglohnsektor jahre lang gefördert
zum beispiel mit der agenda 2010 und den
auswirkungen der hartz reform wir müssen
und wir haben unseren arbeitsmarkt
liberalisiert wir haben einen der besten
niedriglohnsektoren aufgebaut den es in
europa gibt das war 2005
seither gibt es mehr möglichkeiten zur
leiharbeit und seither gilt der
grundsatz fördern und fordern der druck
auf arbeitslose wurde erhöht auch
schlecht bezahlte jobs anzunehmen weil
sonst sanktionen drohen jetzt sind zwar
immer mehr menschen in den arbeitsmarkt
gekommen aber eben auch in schlechte
jobs damit sind die raus aus der
statistik obwohl es sich für sie gar
nicht wirklich lohnt neben hartz4
arbeiten zu gehen
damals hat sich die einschätzung
durchgesetzt dass es besser ist wenn
menschen zu niedrigen löhnen arbeiten
und was vom staat dazu kriegen als wenn
sie arbeitslos sind ich bin davon
überzeugt dass das immer noch richtig
ist da würde mich mal interessieren sind
ihr das genauso
besser einen schlechten job als kein job
schreibt das mal unten in die kommentare
chancen zum aufstieg oder bessere jobs
bekommen die menschen dadurch nicht die
meisten geringverdiener bleiben in
prekären jobs verhältnis in einer
beruflichen sackgasse ohne perspektiven
und mit niedrigem einkommen von daher
ist es auch wenig verwunderlich dass
immer mehr menschen mehr als einen job
haben
2003 hatten knapp 1,4 millionen menschen
mindestens einen nebenjob
heute sind es über drei millionen manche
wollen bewusst flexibel sein aber viele
sind einfach auf ihrem zweiten job
angewiesen
die analyse hat zum beispiel drei jobs
sie kassiert putzt und fährt essen aus
und trotzdem kommt sie kaum über die
runden
wer setzt sich jetzt für diese leute ein
dafür dass arbeitnehmer mehr rechte und
gute verträge haben kämpfen traditionell
gewerkschaften denn sie handeln mit den
arbeitgeberverbänden feste tariflöhne
aus vor 20 jahren war noch so viele
betriebe an tarife gebunden heute sieht
es so aus
in westdeutschland arbeiten nur noch 49
prozent der beschäftigten in einem
betrieb mit tarifbindung in
ostdeutschland sind es 35 prozent
das sind jeweils 21 prozent weniger
experten sehen darin ein hauptgrund für
die schlechteren arbeitsbedingungen und
die geringeren löhne dafür muss man
nämlich auch wissen immer weniger
menschen organisieren sich in
gewerkschaften und damit fehlt den
gewerkschaften die macht in den
lohnverhandlungen der niedriglohnsektor
wurde lange gefördert und die spd will
das jetzt ändern
ausgerechnet die spd die in 16 von 20
jahren den arbeitsminister gestellt hat
und die agenda 2010 eingeführt hat kann
mir vorstellen dass bei vielen der frust
richtig großes nach dem motto york seit
jahren zu wenig getan und uns da raus
und es nämlich so haben es ist zum
problem für den sozialstaat geworden
armut und soziale spaltung in der
gesellschaft haben eine krasse
sprengkraft aber was kann die politik
tun und wie stark sollte sie sich in die
wirtschaft einmischen darüber wird schon
immer und immer wieder gestritten ich
stelle euch mal vier ideen vor
erstens ein höherer mindestlohn
gefordert werden mindestens zwölf euro
pro stunde hier ist die frage ob das
politisch überhaupt umsetzbar ist und
kritiker befürchten außerdem dass
dadurch jobs wegfallen könnten
zweitens natürlich mehr tarifbindung das
bedeutet nämlich nicht nur mehr lohn
sondern auch dinge wie urlaubsgeld
überstunden regelungen und so weiter
hier ist aber die gesamte gesellschaft
gefordert denn dafür müssen sich mehr
menschen in den gewerkschaften
engagieren
eine andere idee ist es bei
geringverdienern die sozialabgaben zu
reduzieren aber hier muss man vorsichtig
sein denn das könnte dazu führen dass im
niedriglohnsektor weiter stabilisiert
wird bei man schlecht bezahlte jobs war
sie staatlich subventioniert
last but not least geht es um mehr
bildung und qualifikation das wird
allgemein sehr gerne gefordert doch auch
hier muss man wissen dass das erstens
lange dauert und zweitens wenn man es
ernst meint aufwendig ist einfach zu
lösen ist das problem jedenfalls nicht
das ziel ist klar armut und ungleichheit
müssen sinken und arbeit muss sich
lohnen und zwar für alle
[Musik]
wenn euch das thema interessiert haben
wir hier noch ein video zu den
fragwürdigen hartz4 kurs und hier einst
zu einem problem dass damit nah verwandt
ist
wenn nämlich wenig verdient kann sich
wohl in deutschland kaum leisten und
hierzulande fehlen tausende
sozialwohnungen